[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de papus
ne vous trompez qu'au monté bien sûr
vous droit ohada tacle au passage il lui
manque un
tout content ou con qui va briller comme
un vrai soleil pata rôle de baliser un
pro bowl à frotey ta voiture
on va plus pâte à tarte étendre le linge
dans le jardin attention à partager bien
qu'il y avait quand même de circuler
- toujours la même chose sans tarder
jamais ou allemands le pied tu crois pas
que c'est de ta faute
fabre actu par leur gardien jamais ce
genre talent cette patate à bâle toi à
moi c'est pas pareil je suis petit je ne
tape pas parce que de faire attention
samba et puis d'abord halak a porté ses
piles de linge mal comme ça avait mal
aux pieds
en benjamins à 12 ans mais toujours
aussi distrait pas tu ajoutes et la
distraction
ça provoque des accidents mort ou le
port marchand c'est très dangereux
la prendre si ça continue faudra aller
se promener chacun son tour
ah ah comme ça pas de risque de
tamponnement nous allons faire une
petite balade pata roule ça te va obama
je vais dire moi je lis pas marchand
mademoiselle bien sûr tu sais pas lire
monsieur moi n'ont par contre je me
souviens qu'à des images de celle ci va
direction le poison attention m meriem
dja ou la saillie m'écraser mais faut
dire tolosa voir si et nbc wigan on l'a
lu j'achète pas d' excuses
depuis cette voiture et dans les talons
et tout marche de travers si c'est pas
vrai peut-être aubin dacquois quoi il ya
des problèmes bon et bien qui dit
problème dissolution c'est à vous de
vous débrouiller
c'est un truc de patates luc ma pauvre
pata rôle on le trouve le truc encore
une fois roues en impasse matin la rend
pas c'est bien qu'on finit surtout corps
alors non seulement quand on est dehors
on se fait renverser par des pâtes à
roullens folie mais quand vont laisser
soin de nous imposer c'est pour votre
sécurité monsieur bord je travaille pour
vous
alors dans ce cas manger à midi
vous êtes cette voie là avec les feux de
signalisation
fini les accidents fini les
embouteillages bon les patins plus
répéter avec moi la leçon de conduite de
l'automobiliste rouge de basses eaux
d'un torrent jonathan vermont passe
encore une fois rouge en impasse au mc
oran girondins larron pas parfait
maintenant monsieur bongo vous êtes au
volant
qu'est ce que vous faites 11
rouge je ne passe pas orange un temps
vers le bas bravo petit clou mais n'est
pas mon ami avec vos feux que se
passe-t-il en cas de panne d'électricité
en cas de tout le monde est chez soi
[Rires]
[Musique]
tata attaquerons à passer le cap au
plafond on chante la chanson j'ai joui
labarthe a plu à capuches se battent à
peluches papa peluche pas inclus
[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pata
peluche ne vous trompez pas monter bien
sûr votre attention
il en manque un
quant aux cons
[Musique]